judges  will choose if we have a tiebreaker  all right jalen green's got oh  no no no no no no he dunks in that is  that like the flavor flavor  that's an nft by the duck with an nft  that thing flies and hits you in your  face be careful that's all i'm saying  gold chain with the nft pendant he's  playing his own highlights  bringing this into the modern day okay  say no more all about to say he's not  dunking i thought he's gonna just tuck  it on his jersey let's go who do you  give this to  isaiah yeah okay  eight tonight  there you go there you go oh just a  regular lob and it works and green's got  one in the books gotta give them some  some eights and i get them seven seven  and eight yeah  seven and eight  thirty nine or forty look at that look  at shaq  jack this is